in movies or TV whenever one character
says to another character can't we just
go back to the way things used to be
it's usually a sign on the part of the
writers that that character has yet to
face up either to reality or to
themselves the cliche is offered up as a
solution some trauma has past parties
that were enraged or hurt or mistaken
one to forgive or heal or apologize they
want the bad times to give way to good
times but only on the pretense the false
pretense that the bad times never happen
this is a kind of red herring of
reconciliation we know that trauma can
be repressed but it can't be erased
lasting reconciliation is achieved by
emotional self-awareness by embracing
the change agents of trauma how they
irreversibly reorganize elements of
personality identity and social reality
this idea the idea of embracing our
wounds our brokenness is manifested
quite poetically in the Japanese mending
practice of kinsuka literally meaning
golden joinery kansui is the art of
fixing broken pottery with lacquer resin
dusted or mixed with powdered gold Asian
cultures have a long history in lacquer
ware though it matured into a
sophisticated art in the Chinese shang
dynasty the earliest discovered
lacquered object dates to the neolithic
hemudu culture in the 5th millennium BC
older than the earth itself according to
young earth creationists pretty
impressive could be alien the various
delicate arts of lacquer ware ramified
and expanded down millenniums and
cultures the story of kansui reportedly
begins in the 15th century with the
japanese military commander the story
goes that famous shogun ashikaga
yoshimasa broke one of his prized
chinese tea bowls so he sent the item
back to China for repair what he got in
return was his bow mended with bulky and
ugly metal staples dismayed yoshimasa
prompted Japanese craftsmen to
search for a more aesthetic means of
repair the art of King Sookie became
famous for turning broken objects into
pieces more beautiful than the original
product there are even rumors of people
breaking their own possessions on
purpose so that they can be mended using
this lovely technique the philosophy
here follows from a broader Japanese
aesthetic called wabi-sabi that finds
beauty not in traditional Western ideals
of symmetry or geometry but in Buddhist
concepts of impermanence and
imperfection the fractures on a ceramic
ball don't represent the end of that
object's life but rather an essential
moment in its history the flaws of its
shape aren't hidden from inspection but
emblazoned with golden significance
maybe Hemingway had consumed his mind
when he wrote that famous line from A
Farewell to Arms the world breaks
everyone and afterward many are strong
in the broken places the amazing art of
Kensuke fading art like so many hand
crafts symbolizes the truth that repair
requires transformation that the
pristine is less beautiful than the
broken and that the shape of us is
impossible to see until it's fractured
until a wound like a crack runs its
length
hey everybody thanks for watching Kim
sook e is just another example of the
profound differences in Western and
Eastern aesthetics and thought there's
not too much to read about it online but
every article that I found I'll put in
the description below under work cited
you can check it out there um thank you
to everybody who followed me on Twitter
following last week's video that was
awesome
if you haven't please do also your
comments on the videos have been amazing
and I'll try to continue to respond to
all of them but if you do want to have a
more involved discussion go to my tumblr
page and use the ask me anything feature
and I'll be able to respond in a sort of
deeper or thoughtful way and as always
throw this video up on reddit if you
found it interesting
reddit has been awesome and I will see
you next time